[Music]
he is
a theatrical legend taking on one of
theater's
legendary roles at 82 serene mckellen
is playing hamlet oh well if the
kidnapped
the tragedy well people of all shapes
sizes and colors
and ages a lot of old actors have played
i think i might just be the oldest i
might have made that
record but i i don't feel uh
and the big bonus for me is actually
quite a lot of stairs on our set
here at windsor and i have to run up and
down them quite a lot and i'm i've never
been so fit
covid brought the curtain crashing down
on the creative arts
and audiences are still small because of
social distancing and only a half full
audience it was rather like turning up
for a thursday matinee you know
become monday that changes and theaters
can fully reopen
i'm a little bit nervous about that i i
dare say the audience will be
nervous too do audiences really want to
come back and sit
next to somebody with with a cough who's
a bit fidgety
i don't know whether our pattern of
behavior in so many areas of life
including going into public places will
have changed
uh but we will swing back to normality
i suspect not for a little bit it's 50
years since sarian was last hamlet
his distinguished career versatile and
varied people who
have influence over the the purse
strings
should realize that it is an investment
uh supporting the arts it's an
investment in in people's
um sense of liveliness and
and community and uh not just
um stimulating the the soul and the
heart and the mind
and the intellect but bringing people
together
shakespeare's greatest tragedy now a
little moment of hope
for theaters audiences and actors
laura bundock sky news windsor